soixante personnalités de renommée
internationale des prix nobel d'anciens
responsables politiques des
intellectuels des artistes sont réunis
depuis lundi au siège de l'unesco pour
parler de l'avenir de la paix l'unesco à
paris il n'y a pas de sujet plus
essentiel pour l'avenir de l'humanité
que l'avenir de la paix ces débats
déboucheront sur des recommandations il
appartiendra aux politiques ensuite de
prendre ou non ses voeux en
considération et là dessus même si on
peut se réjouir d'une aussi riche en
rencontres inspiré par la philosophie et
les sciences humaines ya tout lieu
d'être malheureusement sceptiques sur
son efficacité
ces personnalités dont je viens de vous
parler ont pris aujourd'hui un bain de
jouvence ou même une leçon de concorde
ils ont participé en effet à
l'installation de l'arbre de vie un beau
nom pour une oeuvre collective réalisée
par dix enfants de 5 ans à 12 ans
lauréat du récent concours mondial de
dessins d'enfants et il paraît que pour
peindre et construire ensemble cet arbre
de vie le petit chinois le petit
péruvien le petit japonais le petit
danois et d'autres n'ont eu aucune
difficulté de communication c'est ça la
leçon reportage sur l'arbre de vie
jacques collet par cet arbre de vie
qu'ils ont construit et décorer les
enfants post aux adultes une question
comment vivrons-nous en l'an 2000
question pas si naïve puisqu'elle
correspond au thème des travaux qui
réunissent à l'unesco les représentants
des pays que préoccupe le sort de la
paix
l'arbre de vie est inspiré du baobab
dans lequel chaque branche représente
l'histoire de la vie imaginée par chacun
de ses enfants ce symbole rappelle aux
hommes d'aujourd'hui le terrible danger
devant lequel se trouve l'humanité sans
qu'elles en aient conscience car il n'y
a pas que la guerre nucléaire
aux travaux n'ont abouti à rien au moins
que nous puissions maintenant aboutir un
désarmement général et complet au moins
d'opposition changer l'attitude du
gouvernement vis-à-vis les armes et
vis-à-vis les armements un mois que nous
puissions arriver à faire progrès
complètement d'utilisation d'armes
nucléaires
avec ses dix enfants quatre prix nobel
des écrivains des chercheurs des
cinéastes d'anciens chefs d'état des
poètes même venus d'horizons
géographiques et politiques très
différents pose cette question toute
simple l'humanité veut-elle encore vivre
pour combattre ce doute il faut toute la
foi et la force de conviction de lord
baker qui a plus de 90 ans entreprend
cette véritable croisade pour la paix
donc ça met en présence deux guerres
conventionnelles
quitté des milliers d'êtres humains
presque chaque jour il faut en finir
avec le militarisme avec les théories
t10 oisillons avec les folies
monumentale
qui constituent les armements
d'aujourd'hui
c'est une chose très curie est ce que
l'homme dans la rue
s'intéressent au football
s'intéresse au théâtre au cinéma
aux films à la télévision il ne
s'intéresse pas aux questions de vie et
de mort
mais on va le réveiller
on va faire une propagande d'une
éducation mondiale
pour lui faire comprendre
qu'il a maintenant in choix
il soit en un monde qui s'y lie à la
guerre
deviendra aussi désert
aussi silencieuse que la lune
est un monde bien un amende
qui pourrait être
glorieux
voilà à méditer